So, today we're going to
continue with our series of
lectures to come to a conclusion
from the section on population
and community ecology.
At last time,
or three lectures ago,
we were talking about the
regulation of population growth.
And this time,
we're going to move into,
just wanted to make sure the
boards are in order,
community ecology.
And as I said of the first
lecture, this is one of the most
difficult branches of the
ecological sciences to really
describe because an ecological
community is a bit of an
abstract concept.
And one definition is that it's
a collection of species that are
linked together by their feeding
relationships.
00:01:29<clear/>
OK, so it's sort of like the
ecosystem without the
biogeochemistry in a sense.
So really what we're looking at
here is the interaction between
species in a localized area with
respect to how they influence
each other's fitness,
in a sense.
And these interrelationships
between these species govern all
of the things that we talked
about in the first half of my
lectures set.
It's these interactions that
shape the biogeochemistry of
those systems.
So, this is the structure of
the system and the
biogeochemistry is the function
of the system.
And it's also these
interactions.
So, they affect the flow of
energy, which we talked about.
They affect the cycling of
elements.
They affect the evolution,
the very evolution of species
within the community.
And these communities self
assemble.
In other words,
if you start with an empty plot
of bare land,
we talked about this.
Remember the example of the
glacier retreating and showing
the succession of species as the
glacier retreated?
We started with a bare rock,
and you'll start getting lichen
growing on the rock.
And then that lichen will
create a little bit of soil,
allowing plants to come in,
and that the plants increase
productivity.
Some of them bring nitrogen
and, allowing shrubs and trees
and everything.
And that's the self-assembly of
the community.
Once you have plant there,
you can have insects there.
Once you have insects there,
you have birds there.
It self assembles.
And one of the questions that
ecologists ask is,
how deterministic is that?
I mean, we know there are some
random components to it,
and we know that there are some
things that will happen because
we see it happen over,
and over, and over.
So the big question is what
must happen?
What could happen?
And what might not ever happen?
That's really one of the
challenges of ecologists is to
understand those assembly rules
of community if there are any.
Now, we're not going to really
get into that.
We are just going to start
looking at the real fundamentals
of community [SOUND OFF/THEN ON]
which is, what are the possible
interactions between species
that shape evolution?
OK.
00:04:57<clear/>
Species interactions:
so, when we talk about species
interactions and how they
structure communities,
we have to first define some
terms.
One is Darwinian fitness.
00:05:27<clear/>
And the fitness of an
individual is the relative
ability of an individual in a
population to survive and
reproduce.
00:06:07<clear/>
So, it's all relative,
OK, within a population.
And we're going to define also,
we'll be talking about
adaptations, and I know you know
what this is,
but let's just make sure that
we are all operating with the
same assumption.
And an adaptation,
which is something that affects
the fitness, is a heritable
trait that increases the fitness
of an individual with respect to
other individuals in that
population.
So, these are just some
operating assumptions so that
when we talk about species
interactions,
there are several
possibilities.
If we have organism one and
organism two,
we can have,
and we ask how does the
presence of organism two and the
presence of organism one affect
the fitness of the two
organisms?
And if the fitness of both
organisms is increased by being
in the presence of the other,
that's called mutualism.
Being together increases the
fitness of both relative to when
they're alone.
If being together decreases the
fitness of both,
that's called competition.
And if you have the situation,
what we recall that?
It could be parasitism,
yeah, parasitism.
What else?
Was the ultimate form of
reduced fitness?
Predation, yeah,
being dead is the ultimate
reduced fitness.
So, parasitism and predation.
And then there are some other
sort of rather vague
interactions where when you put
two individuals together,
the fitness of one is not
influenced but the fitness of
the other is either influenced
positively or negatively,
and we're not going to talk
about those.
But this one's called
commencalism.
And this one's called
amensalism.
And obviously there are
gradients.
Actually, an example of
commencalism is something that
we've talked about.
Can anybody think about what
that is when we talked about
food webs?
It's kind of a stretch,
but detritivory.
An organism eating detritus,
in a sense, is commencalism
because it doesn't affect the
fitness of the dead individual
because it's already dead.
So, that gets to not having
that much meaning.
So anyway, these we are not
going to spend time on,
but they are forms of
interaction that do exist.
And there are gradients between
these.
Obviously, it's not all black
and white.
So, we're going to start by
talking about competition.
And just to remind you,
competition comes in two forms.
There is intraspecific
competition, which means within
a species, OK?
And that's not what we're going
to be talking about today,
but we've already talked about
this without explicitly,
remember our logistic equation
and the density dependent
feedback mechanisms in that
population that caused the
population to deviate from
exponential growth was due to
intraspecific competition:
individuals within a species
competing with each other for
resources.
We are going to talking about
now is more interspecific --
00:12:01<clear/>
-- which is competition between
species, OK?
So, I want to show you some
slides that are just from your
textbook, but just to get you in
the mood for competition.
So, it comes in all different
forms, and I don't care whether
you know the names of these.
It doesn't matter.
This is just to give you an
idea of the different types of
competition that we see in
nature.
This is what's called
consumptive competition,
and this is just showing the
roots of the trees competing for
nutrients in the soil.
Preemptive competition shows
these are barnacles.
We're going to talk a little
bit more about that later,
just totally taking over the
substrate.
So no other organism could
possibly settle there.
Overgrowth competition in
plants where this plant would be
shading, so other plants that
require a lot of light could not
grow underneath.
Chemical competition also
occurs where one plant will
actually excrete certain
chemicals that create these
corridors of no growth around
them so other plants can't get
near to compete for the
nutrients.
The classic form of
competition, say,
in birds and a lot of higher
organisms is competition for
territory.
So these are displays so that
an individual can keep a certain
territory, and therefore make
that food available to itself,
therefore increasing its
fitness because it's able to
feed its young.
And then this is sort of the
classic, really tooth and claw
competition where encounter
competition where all these
species are competing over this
zebra carcass,
hyena, vultures,
etc.
OK, now before we can talk more
and more in detail about
competition, we need to define
the ecological niche.
And this is an interesting
concept in ecology that has been
around for quite some time,
and it kind of went out of
popularity for a while.
And I was gratified to see that
it's made it back into the
introductory biology textbooks
because I think it's a very
profound concept.
In this particular competition,
the fundamental ecological
niche comes from G.
Evelyn Hutchinson,
who is one of the founders of
modern ecology.
He defined as the fundamental
niche of an organism as an
N-dimensional hypervolume,
every point on which a species
can survive and reproduce
indefinitely in the absence of
other species,
OK?
So, this is an abstract
concept, because those species
are rarely in the absence of
other species,
except maybe in a test tube.
But it defines the,
and also we can't even think
about N-dimensions,
right?
We're able to think about,
we can envision three
dimensions.
But what he's talking about
here, is every single dimension
in the environment that would
have any effect on the fitness
of an organism.
So here, just to wrap our
brains around this,
we're looking at three
dimensions.
Our organisms here is a
ladybug, and this would be food
size.
These guys eat little aphids
and things.
I don't know if you've ever
used them under house plants,
but it's a good way to keep
aphids off your house plants if
you want to introduce ladybugs
to your dorm room,
which maybe you don't.
But there's a certain range of
size, food size,
that they can eat.
And so, that's three
dimensions.
There are undoubtedly many
other dimensions that we don't
even know about,
elements that they require,
etc.
So, this would be everywhere,
in this space is a space where
this organism could survive and
reproduce indefinitely.
And the reason this concept
lost favor is its something you
could never ever measure this
because we can't know the
N-dimensions.
Well, you can never say you
can't know anything,
but it's very difficult to say
you could know all the
dimensions that influence the
fitness of an organism.
But it's still a very important
concept for thinking about it.
And the niche is not a physical
place, OK?
The niche of an organism is not
a physical place.
In an N-dimensional
hypervolume.
It's an abstract concept.
So this is the fundamental
niche, and here's another
closely related species whose
niche has some overlap with this
one, but has different ranges
for temperature,
humidity, and food size.
And when you have overlapping
niches is when you have the
possibility, the potential,
for competition.
And two things can happen.
If they overlap a lot,
than those two species cannot
coexist in the same environment.
One will outcompete the other,
and it will move on to some
other place where it doesn't
have a strong competitor.
But if they overlap a little,
you can actually have
competitive coexistence.
And we're going to talk about
the results of these degrees of
niche overlap as we go on in the
lecture.
So, if the species can makes it
realized, so this is its
fundamental niche,
this one's fundamental niche,
and what happens if it can make
its realized niche small enough
so that there's no niche
overlap, then you can have
coexistence of those two
species, or very little niche
overlap in the same environment.
So that's the difference
between the fundamental and the
realized niche.
I think this is from your
textbook.
This is just one dimension,
seed sized, for,
say, a bird eating seeds of
this size range.
We'll be talking about birds a
lot in this.
And here's partial niche
overlap, species to where they
eat some seeds of the same size,
but by and large the mode is
different.
You can have species
coexisting.
Partial niche overlap can lead
to competitive coexistence.
And here's the complete overlap
in just this one dimension,
which would lead to competitive
exclusion.
But obviously it matters what's
happening on all the dimensions.
This is just an
oversimplification,
to give you the idea.
OK, so before we go to that,
I want to talk about the
classic experiment that led to
this, they're going to put this
screen up.
Screen, screen,
screen, screen.
00:20:35<clear/>
Can you see,
or do I need to turn the lights
on?
Thank you.
I'm sorry, I always ask my
questions that way,
where there's no possible
answer.
00:21:06<clear/>
There were some classic
competition experiments that's
carried out by Gause way back in
1934 --
-- that I'm just going to use
to illustrate the concept of
competitive exclusion,
because these were done with
very simple protozoa in a test
tube, paramecia,
and actually this was back in
the days when they were
developing these theories for
population growth.
And these organisms were
growing according to the
logistic equation.
So here we are with,
and this is the classic
experiment actually in your
textbook that they talk about in
the context of the ecological
niche.
So this is Paramecia caudatum.
These names aren't important.
Don't worry about it,
but we have to call them
something.
P.
aurelia, which,
when grown alone in a test tube
grow according to the logistic
equation, they grow up and then
they level off at a certain
level.
And what Gause did is that he
wanted to see,
look at this phenomenon of
competition and he grew them
together, and he found that,
actually that no matter what
combination he put in,
aurelia would always win out in
competitive exclusion.
00:23:13<clear/>
And he learned through a series
of experiments,
we don't have time to go into
the details, but this would
always occur if you made two
species compete in a very simple
environment.
In the test tube where he was
feeding these guys exactly the
same food, some form of
bacteria, in a test tube this
one would always outcompete the
other, and there would be
competitive exclusion.
If he made the environment more
complex, where there were layers
in it, or there was sediment in
the bottom of the test tube,
that allowed more niche
dimensions.
There were conditions under
which the competitive
coexistence would be allowed.
And he actually developed a set
of equations to describe his
competition that I'm going to
write for you.
We're not going to use them;
we're not going to analyze them
in detail, but I'm just going to
show them to you so that you
have an appreciation for how
population ecologists and
community ecologists start to
think about these systems.
So, he said we can model this
interaction using our logistic
equation.
So he said dN/dt would be the
growth rate of,
let's call, the top one,
one.
It doesn't matter what you call
which.
The dN/dt equals r1,
N1.
Now here's our logistic,
K1 minus N1 over K.
But he said I'm going to modify
this equation so that the actual
growth of the organism is
reduced to some amount that's
proportional to the number of
the other organisms that are
there.
So, he called that alpha-N2.
OK, so some amount that's
proportional to amount the other
species that's here.
And then, he said dN2/DT is
equal to r2, N2,
K2 minus N2 minus beta-N1 over,
this should be K1,
over K2.
So, the growth rate of species
to in the presence of species
one is reduced by some amount
that's proportional to the
abundance of species one.
And these, the values of these,
these are called competition
coefficients.
You can actually do experiments
and put values on these,
and they are a measure of how
strong a competitor each of
these species are with respect
to the other one.
So, you're not going to have to
deal with these,
but I just wanted you to see
them, and see how population
ecologists began to model these
systems.
And so, it's the relative
values of these relative to the
carrying capacities that will
ultimately determine whether
species will coexist or not when
they are competing.
OK, so that's more of a
theoretical analysis.
Now let's look at the real
world.
Competitive exclusion,
that is, the exclusion of one
species from an environment
because of strong competition in
another, is very difficult to
study, because if it's not
there, you don't know it was
excluded, right?
I mean, you don't go to some
place and say I don't see the
species here.
It must have been eliminated by
competitive exclusion.
It might never have been there.
So, the way we learn about this
phenomenon is either through
inadvertent experiments,
and that is the introduction of
species to new environments and
then see what happens,
or actual intentional
ecological experiments.
So, we're going to talk about
both of those.
And the first one --
00:28:01<clear/>
-- we'll talk about invasions --
00:28:12<clear/>
-- and competitive exclusion.
And one of the classic examples
of this is the zebra mussel.
I don't know what happened.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't realize this was
animated.
That's why there was nothing
there.
So, the zebra mussel is a tiny
mussel that was introduced to
the United States back in,
I guess, 1988.
And up here,
introduced into the Great Lakes
by ships just being attached to
ships, or it's possible it might
have been the larvae in ships'
ballasts.
Ships go into port,
they take on water into their
ballasts to stabilize,
and then they go to another
port and let it out.
And they're filled with larvae
and species.
So, the entire world oceans are
now filled with introduced
species from ships ballasts.
So here's 1988.
The zebra mussel is there.
1990: here.
92: here.
94, 90 whatever,
oh, 2001.
It spread amazingly fast.
And it is this tiny little
mussel that seems to thrive
everywhere: clogs,
all kinds of pipes,
settles on top of other native
shellfish and kills them,
and has led to extensive
competitive exclusion of native
shellfish in a number of
ecosystems.
Some of the effects of these:
in some ecosystems they cleared
up the water.
They are able to filter just an
amazing amount of water when
they're feeding.
So they actually have increased
the clarity of the water in many
ecosystems, filtering out
plankton, which allows the light
to penetrate deeper in those
systems, allowing aquatic plants
to grow from the bottom.
So the introduction of this one
species can completely change
the structure of the entire
ecosystem.
I just heard a lecture.
I was just visiting the
Institute for Ecosystem Studies
which is out in Millbrook,
NY.
By the way, if any of you are
looking for summer internships
and are interested in ecology,
they have a fabulous summer
internship program.
I've had several students go
there that have had great
experiences.
But there's somebody there
studying the zebra mussel
invasion in the Hudson River.
And he showed this incredibly
depressing graph of over the
last ten years of the native
mussels in that river going down
to basically extinction.
And then, this is the weird
thing about ecosystems,
just last year it started to
turn around.
And they haven't done anything
to eradicate the zebra mussels,
but the native mussels are
starting to have a comeback.
And nobody knows why,
and nobody knows whether it's a
real comeback because it could
come back for a couple of years.
So, it's really interesting how
unpredictable these complex
systems are.
But these mussels can cause
millions and millions of dollars
of damage.
And I also learned on that trip
that ecologists are trying to
get in place policies that if an
industry for whatever reasons
wants to intentionally
introduce,
Here's an example of an
application of fundamental
ecological knowledge.
The reason people study the
ecology of invasive species,
understanding this competitive
exclusion and all that,
is that you want to use that
understanding to be able to
predict, if you introduce a new
species to a new habitat,
whether it will be invasive or
not, there are some species you
can introduce and they will fit
right in and not exclude every
other species.
And so, what they're trying to
put in place is insurance that a
company would have to buy that
was either intentionally
introducing a species,
or whatever practice that they
were doing was likely to
introduce a species,
and the cost of that insurance
would be a function of the
probability of that species
actually causing competitive
exclusion.
And this is something that
people are trying to put into
place in to the economic system
basically.
So, it puts a new meaning to
limited liability company,
LLC.
So, you have to insure your
liability, which I think would
go a long way to reduce some of
these ecological crises.
OK, so that's an inadvertent
experiment.
Now there are many,
many examples of this.
There's books written on
invasive species.
And if I can get this thing to
work, I'll show you some clips
of invasive species,
snakes.
And the biggest impact is on
islands because islands have
been isolated ecosystems for so
long that if you introduce a
species, you have dramatic
changes.
In Australia,
a big example was a prickly
pear cactus which was introduced
many years ago to create living
fences for livestock.
They completely took over not
all of the grasslands,
but a lot of the grasslands and
turn them into thickets.
OK, so invasive species are
inadvertent ecological
experiments.
Let's talk about intentional
And this is also very classic
textbook experiment that was one
of the first ecological
experiments to be done.
And it was done with barnacles.
This was Joseph Connell was a
professor at the University of
California, Santa Barbara.
Barnacles have a larval stage
that floats around in the
plankton, and then they settle
on rocks.
So this was a classic barnacle
ecosystem in Scotland,
actually, in which the upper
inner tidal there is a species
called Chthamalus.
And then the lower was
dominated by a species of mussel
called Balanus.
So, he asked the question,
is this distribution where the
two are exclusive of one
another, is it due to
competition between them,
or is it just that this one
tolerates desiccation longer
than this one?
The inner tidal zone,
the tide goes up and down,
so this one's going to be
exposed to dryness a lot longer.
So, how do you answer that
question?
Well, you do an experiment and
so what he did was he took rocks
from the upper,
inner tidal that had the
Chthamalus on them,
and he moved them to the lower
one.
And he let the Balanus,
the species that dominates down
here colonize on those rocks.
But then he divided them in
half, and removed the Balanus
from half of the rock.
And then he monitored the
survivorship of the Chthamalus.
And remember the survivorship
curves that we talked about when
we created those life tables,
he actually measured
survivorship curves on these.
If you go to the original
paper, you see LX is a function
of time.
So that's a tool that we use,
to ask the question,
is the survivorship of
Chthamalus increased in the
absence of Balanus?
And this is all from your
textbook, showing that the
percent of mortality,
when a competitor is present is
much higher than the competitor
is absent.
So, he's able to show directly
that there was competition
between the two.
And in fact,
this was that kind of
aggressive kind of competition
where one just plucks the other
one off the rock.
I mean it's direct:
you're on my rock;
get out of here,
and it pops it off.
He also was able to show that
tolerance to desiccation is also
a factor in this system.
It's not like it's totally
competition.
But competition was playing a
role, and so I've summarized
that in this slide using our
terminology.
He was able to show that the
fundamental niche of Chthamalus,
in other words --
-- the region in the inner
tidal, where the larvae could
actually settle and live in the
absence of competitors was much
broader than the realized niche.
All right, so let's get this
over.
This is from your textbook.
And we're going to just use,
I'm going to use an example of
that.
So, competition can also lead
to character displacement --
00:39:04<clear/>
-- which in turn can lead to
actual competitive coexistence.
And an example of this,
we're going to talk about
Darwin's finches in the
Galapagos Islands.
And one of the ways that
ecologists actually measure,
that's a bird,
in case you didn't notice it.
And this is beak depth.
The shape and size of a beak
tells you what kinds of seeds a
bird can eat,
and so they measured beak depth
as a niche dimension,
basically, because it tells you
what size seeds the bird can
eat.
And a study was done;
we're going to make the islands
here.
What is going to call them A,
B, C, D; these are islands.
And there are two species of
finches, which we are just going
to call F.
Well, they're fuliginosa.
Again, the name's not
important, and the other one is
called fortis.
So, we'll just call them,
on islands that have both of
them, and there are some islands
that have only one.
So, what was done is they
measure the beak depth of the
different finches on the islands
where they were found together
versus islands where they were
found alone in the Galapagos
Islands.
And what they found,
and this has been shown for
many, many different studies.
You look at the beak depth
distribution.
00:41:53<clear/>
This is percent in size class.
And this is island C,
D, and A, and B.
And they found that when the
species were on islands where
they lived alone,
they had almost complete niche,
oh this is beak depth.
They had exactly the same size
beak distributions.
In other words,
they were feeding on the same
food.
And on the islands where they
were together,
A and B, I'm just making sure
this actually holds together,
they found what is called
character displacement,
and that is that the birds that
had longer beaks and smaller
beaks, were preferentially
selected for such that reducing
the amount of niche overlap.
So, and this leads to
competitive coexistence.
OK, and that's what we're
looking at here.
This is from your textbooks.
This is from African seed
crackers showing that birds with
smaller bills consume soft seeds
more efficiently.
Birds with larger bills crack
hard seeds, and you can see that
the width of the bill here is
different.